fait dégager le plus possible à part
côté tableau et essayer de faire d un
art de un arc de cercle ou deux arc de
cercle pour que tout le monde soit bien
espacées l'heure est à la préparation de
la rentrée des classes du 12 mai 2020 à
l'école maternelle francine froment 20
enfants seront accueillis sur la
centaine d'inscrits dans cette classe de
petite section de maternelle quatre
élèves seront présents demain
chacun aura son espace avec deux tables
un tapis et son matériel
ils ont déjà des feutres un cahier de
dessin chacun ils ont six au pinceau de
cole écoles ils ont leila 3 puzzle pour
lui il ya les prix les lettres de son
prénom armée a reconstitué dans l'ordre
je vais lui les placer le modèle et j'ai
installé des livres et des jeux de
construction en plus des masques des
lingettes du gel hydroalcoolique ces
équipements seront fournis aux
enseignants et au personnel éducatif
marquage au sol indications sur les murs
de l'établissement
une nouvelle organisation pour respecter
les règles de distanciation sociale les
25 écoles de la ville ont mis en place
leur propre système
la décision de rouvrir les écoles
étaient assez évidente pour nous parce
que nous avons fait aussi le constat
durant ces huit semaines de confinement
maintenant qu'un certain nombre
d'enfants avaient impérativement besoin
de revenir à l'école alors on a des
arrivées échelonnées le matin par
exemple sur deux créneaux
8h20 8h30 8h35 8h45
même chose pour les sorties parce que
c'est surtout sur ces temps là aussi
qu'il faut faire attention qu'il n'est
pas de regroupement à l'entrée des
écoles le temps périscolaire sera aussi
assurée par la commune les accueils de
loisirs seront ouverts le mercredi un
accueil destinés aux enfants scolarisés
sur la ville